Well,
November the 26th 2017 a hundred euros
held elections,
some very peculiar elections,
even though millions of people were
called upon to vote that day.
Only one vote really counts and in the
end,
and that was the vote of the president's
one whole Ando Hernandez who decided to
stay for another four years.
No nuts or what the polls said.
Joe,
look at Dana.
Yeah,
this president's Hernandez very probably
just told himself,
well,
hey,
I like being president a lot.
So why leave?
Wow.
Since then,
protests due to what has obviously been
a rigged election and assault on
democracy have occurred quite
frequently.
Honduras is a country that already
suffers from the tragic consequences of
a social and political model full of
corruption and violence.
How model,
dear viewer,
that is so disastrous and dysfunctional
that it let Honduras to be the poorest
country in Latin America and the third
most dangerous country in the world's,
which isn't presently at war.
Cool.
See,
Honduras is a small tropical country
with just over 9 million inhabitants.
The cases on a narrow strip of land that
separates the Caribbean sea from the
Pacific Ocean.
Yeah.
Okay.
Indeed.
Honduras is one of those places where we
can find some of the most incredible
beaches in the world.
Wow.
Sandy,
crystal clear waters and lots and lots
of coconut trees.
Okay.
Sounds rather nice.
It doesn't it as I,
fortunately,
drug trafficking gangs and a political
and economic elites have prioritized
above all plundering of a nation's
resources.
They have muddied and stains the reality
of a country that could otherwise be
safe and possibly even be considered a
true paradise here on earth.
Some people don't want to come here to
claim bodies because they don't want to
be associated with their family member
who ends up dead because here this gang
members come here to the medical
examiners office and they case out
families to figure out who is next in
that family unit that they would be
attacked.
Let's,
you might be thinking right now,
I mean a small remote,
poor country,
just another drop in the ocean of
problems.
I said,
well,
wait a minute,
because there's a lot more at work.
Yeah.
What would you think if I told you that
we might be facing the first coup de ta
supported by the trump administration?
Well,
just check this out.
Okay.
Fraud.
Awesome.
On Sunday,
November the 26th 2017
general elections were held in Honduras
and there were two major contenders for
the presidency,
which is the most important political
position in the country.
On the one hands,
we've got president one Alando
Hernandez,
who was widely supported by the
country's economic leadership and the
international community,
and he was aspiring to be reelected or
reelection.
By the way,
that was very controversial because in
principle,
the country's constitution prevents it
under article 239 and article that was
declared in applicable in 2015 by a
surprising and very controversial
decision from the Supreme Court.
Now,
do bear in mind here that the supreme
court is in actuality controlled by the
presidents,
so maybe that might have had something
to do with it.
It's just maybe is gay and Lasalla
constitutional to show me
this is what article 239 set.
If a citizen has held the ownership of
the executive power,
he or she cannot be the president or
designee.
Article two 39 of the Honduran
Constitution.
Now,
on the other hand,
Salvador Nasralla,
right?
Popular television presents that ran as
a candidate for the center left parties
coalition,
the opposition alliance
slavery.
I think that is,
or or we didn't say yes that moment
though,
Latina Scitech,
whatever.
So even you must go amigo.
Well,
the fact is that in the initial vote
counts,
everything pointed to Salvador.
Nasralla is
sorry.
With almost 60% of the votes counted,
he had a five point lead over the
president's.
The advantage was so overwhelming that
the magistrates who formed the Honduras
Supreme Electoral Tribunal qualified
this lead as irreversible and
insurmountable.
However,
suddenly the counting stopped,
there was no additional information.
Can we use a system?
Simply collapsed.
New balance appeared and in the end,
several days later,
the electorial tribunal awarded a
surprising victory to precedent one
Orlando Hernandez,
one lieutenant [inaudible].
Then when it's so many irregularities
that the organization of American States
of self rejected the recounts and calls
for new elections.
It's a good video.
[inaudible] Ella oil proponent
[inaudible] he gets it,
but he's,
and the impulsivity that [inaudible]
but that's not all.
One day before the elections,
the economist published on its website
that he'd had a recording that proved
the government was preparing to distort
the results of this
[inaudible].
So the big
question now is,
well,
was the election actually,
now that is hard to say for sure,
but let's just say that the chances are
really,
really high.
All of this is without mentioning the
governments authoritarian behavior.
Of course,
once the possibility of electoral fraud
was on the table,
the opposition mobilized and organized
protest rallies.
They were peaceful at first,
but the police didn't really seem to
cap.
They still used as much force on the
protesters as they want it.
For example,
on the evening of Wednesday,
the 29th state forces fired tear gas at
a rally of about a thousand people who
were peacefully awaiting the results.
Indeed.
In this group there was even the
opposition leader,
Salvador Nasralla,
the police,
they didn't care that it was a peaceful
demonstration or that they were children
and elderly people
present.
No
g
even decreed a curfew,
and since then rallies have been put
down with 30 people being killed and is
more than 800 people being detained.
In other words,
the evidence really does point to a
rigged election followed by forceful
repression or simply to reinforce the
victory.
Okay,
Nadia.
Now having said that,
we have several questions that need an
answer and it's clearly one of them is
who exactly is the president?
Who is Juan Orlando Hernandez,
the president,
two versions and they're really
different interpretations.
The first is that of a leader with a
strong hands,
but who can clearly rescue his country
from becoming a failed state.
The second is that of an authoritarian
leader involved in corruption and crime,
a leader who was taking control of the
country's institutions and to managers
them based on his own interests.
This is something we saw in the case of
the Supreme Court and reelection.
Bang.
The president,
as we will see in more detail in a
moment,
has the support of the United States of
America,
among others,
and it'd be fair,
we must say that his mandate has had
many dark times,
but it's also had some good ones.
Let's start with these good ones.
See,
when Kwan Orlando Hernandez came to
power in 2013 on has had the highest
homicide rates of a country that was not
at war.
Every 13 hours a woman is murdered in
this country,
the number of violent of women in
Honduras has risen 260% it is true that
nowadays the country,
it's still has a serious problem.
It is still ranked the third west
country when it comes to homicides in
relation to its population.
And further,
there's the problem,
but 90% of these crimes remain
unpunished,
but things while they have improved,
in fact,
this is the president's main pride,
them
joy
in the United States,
the governments often jurists has
created a new special police force,
which is financed,
equipped,
and trained by the dea and FBI among
others.
At the same time it is expelled and
replaced thousands of corrupt agents.
It has dismantled several drug cartels
and extradited dozens of drug
traffickers to the United States and
even created parks around the country
which are guarded by the military police
so that children and families can enjoy
their leisure time safely.
I look Joe Folio platform aspect.
We went by Ethan medicine.
So far so good,
right?
But unfortunately their view of the
story does not end there with rainbows
and butterflies
is
is player evidence of the presidents
corruption.
In fact,
the 2013 election campaign that brought
him to power was financed by money
stolen from the Honduran Institute of
Social Security and there are even well
founded suspicions that presidents or
Lando cause connections with drug
trafficking group,
illegal drug trade in Honduras,
not only infected much of its civil
society,
including the highest levels of
government and its financial sector,
but also brought frightening levels of
violence to its people.
June h Kim,
the acting United States attorney in
Manhattan.
In any case,
whether these accusations are true or
not,
repression,
deception,
and it's controlling,
institutions can neither be justified.
Snore contribution to Honduras,
being able to overcome the problems that
impede its development.
The president has clear support from the
international community.
He has received money,
police aid and its military and
political support,
and the truth is the people,
they expected something different.
Bus,
of course,
Divya,
all of this isn't that strange in this
country.
Okay.
A cocktail
of corruption and violence.
Honduras is facing a difficult problem
that is a triangle of interrelated
powers that make being an optimist in
Honduras,
very,
very difficult political power.
The economic oligarchy and drug
traffickers grabs the most
representative case of all this.
Is that a fabby Yo Lobo,
he's the son of Porphyria Lobo,
the former president of the republic who
was just been sentenced in the United
States to 24 years in prison for his
involvement and activities as a drug
trafficker.
He actually did this when his father was
president of the republic and no,
we're not talking about a rebellious son
or anything like that.
It's drug trafficking,
by the way.
It's currently the country's main
economic activity.
[inaudible]
we'll fed thick on it.
I hold them.
We changed it to [inaudible] Sierras.
Another example is the New York Times
reported is parliaments.
It's an underequipped building from the
1950s that lacks the minimum necessary
conditions,
which contrast with the deputies parking
lost a parking lots that is full of off
road vehicles.
All the latest and most expensive
models,
and this affects practically everyone,
but if the governments and as the
opposition,
the police and security forces entre
moved from this,
either extortion and bribery is common
and it's widely known that police
members have ties with gangs and drug
traffickers.
Mara Salvatrucha gangsters in Rivera
Hernandez say they receive warnings from
the police of impending sweeps and are
handed captured rivals to execute for
anything from $440 to $2,200
ahead.
Sonia Nazario,
Pulitzer Prize winning journalist,
politicians,
security forces,
gangs,
drug traffickers,
and lastly the economic oligarchy.
[inaudible]
10 families controlled practically every
economic resource and have no problems
paying bribes and displacing trustworthy
people in the powerful positions do
generate something that is not a market
model,
but a model that is entirely controlled
by the institution.
This nice to have a highly extractive
results network,
and it's ultimately responsible for
Honduras and knots being that paradise
that we discussed at the beginning of
the video.
But we also mentioned the u s
government,
specifically the trump administration as
possibly being responsible for what
happens with Honduras is elections.
So let's get into it.
Washington's important,
yeah,
be forgiven for thinking initially that
Honduras is not that important to
Washington DC rice,
but not exactly the truth is that
Honduras has a certain importance to the
United States for three main reasons.
Firstly,
because a lot of the flights suspected
of transporting drugs from South America
have to first stop in this country.
Exactly.
They think is two years ago,
faced with countries,
enormous crisis,
18,000
a year in children traveled alone to the
United States border,
and nobody in Washington really wants to
see that happen again.
And thirdly,
because Honduras has traditionally been
an allied country,
in fact,
the United States has had a military
base there for decades.
Due to all of this,
the u s has spent billions of dollars in
Honduras in recent years to try and
reverse the country's problems.
While the trump administration,
it knows this,
and this is why it supports Juan Orlando
Hernandez.
Indeed,
this is what a prominent Republican
advisor said about the matter.
Washington
has invested significant money in
Central America to help turn the
security and economic situation around.
If Hernandez loses the election,
the United States will have no effective
partners in the region.
The effectiveness of our billions would
be at risk and more people might be to
come to
the United States.
Danielle ruined day or Republican
foreign policy adviser and former
official of the George W.
Bush administration.
Yes,
Washington support is clear.
In fact,
the police,
which were trains and financed by the
United States,
participated in the post electoral
events without any complaints from the u
s embassy.
And this is because the u s government
fears the tires that Salvador Nasralla
his candidacy you could have with the
Cuban regime and even the regime of
Maduro in Venezuela.
This is something,
by the way,
that the candidate deniers,
they're wrong because my model is based
in Uruguay or Chili's,
moderate left or Costa Rica's moderate,
right?
One thing is the friendship that my
ideological partner,
Manuel's Aaliyah has with Maduro Miralis
and something very different is what I
think me who would be the President
Salvador Nasralla.
Anyway,
for everyone watching this video from
Honduras,
we should state that things can change
and do tend to change.
There's the case of Columbia as an
example.
One,
I was the alternate.
Do you think that we could possibly be
facing the first cue to tar backs by the
trump administration?
Well,
leave your answer in the comments below
as well as in this survey and I really
hope you enjoy this video.
Please hit that like button if you did
and do not forget to subscribe to our
channel for brand new videos every
Monday and Thursday.
Also,
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast or they
provided the vocals in this episode,
but we're not mine and as always,
thanks for [inaudible].
Nadia.